[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul in this video we're
breaking down the penultimate episode of
lovecraft country
by this point this series is really
going off on its own tangent
and it's interesting for fans like me
that love the book but are also excited
to see how things are going with this
new direction
we're going to be breaking it all down
but obviously there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't seen the
episode yet then i highly recommend that
you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day and
please drop a thumbs up if you've been
enjoying the coverage
thank you as always for clicking the
video now let's get into the breakdown
okay so episode 9 is titled rewind in
1921
and it sees our cast of characters
traveling back to the air in question
to witness the tulsa massacre firsthand
it's a heartbreaking episode
i can imagine a lot of people myself
included
finding to be a very difficult watch the
massacre happened in tulsa oklahoma on
may 31st
and lasted for several days it involved
white racists descending on black owned
businesses and residents
and the police and national guard
actually enabled this even deputising
some members of the mob so that their
attacks were classed as being operated
within the law
they destroyed over 35 blocks in the
area
injured over 800 people and led to the
death of 36 members of the public
it was overlooked throughout history and
kind of brushed under the rug to the
point that a lot of people
including me thought that its inclusion
in watchmen was 100 fictional
the episode very much carries the notion
of generational violence committed
against the black community
and several of the characters we
encounter embody the past
sacrificing themselves for the future
it's very much about accepting that we
all have a responsibility to take
accountability for things
and i thought that this was kind of
hinted at in the opening of the episode
with everyone pointing fingers at each
other over who was to blame for what
happened to dee
after topsy and bopsy caught up to her
her arms started to wither
and we discovered throughout the century
that she's transforming into a monster
herself
as the group are out of their depth when
it comes to handling magic
atticus says that he's going to reach
out to christina and will hand over
titus's pages
something which we know could spell
death for him however
letty informs him that she's already
gave them to christina
i think it's quite ironic how she went
to christina last week trying to get
protection for him
but ultimately may have just sealed his
fate the clues were there when christina
refused to make tick invulnerable
and we do start to get more hints about
her overall agenda in this century
tempers flare and ruby steps in saying
that lady had to protect herself
but she doesn't reveal a pregnancy just
yet and instead puts herself forward as
a way to contact christina
both sides already know about the
pregnancy and it further hammers home
this idea of secrets
which has been laced throughout the
season we see a piece of paper with the
ali assault from last week on it
and the words the captain's not going to
ask you again girl
because of the detail in the work
christina is able to pinpoint exactly
which pages it came from
and thus she realizes that lancaster is
the only way to lift this spell
due to a lot of these texts no longer
being available
christina says she will reset the
process but in exchange
tick must come to autumn on the night of
the autonomal equinox
she states that dee needs the blood of
her closest relative
in order to perform this and with
hippolyta gone
and the way things stand that is
currently montrose
however as we've been theorizing george
may actually be
atticus's true father and that would
make him the closest relative
which puts montrose in a sticky position
as he doesn't know whether to fess up
and put his son in danger or not
the pair shares several big scenes
together and though we don't know for
definite yet i do think that montrose
will actually be revealed as his true
father
i think that's how the show will end
with them embracing one another finally
able to know everything about one
another but it could really go either
way
keep an eye out for next week now
montrose drinks george's moonshine
titled road rash
and as we know the character used to
constantly travel in order to write his
safe travel guide
therefore the term road rash ties in
with traveling and in case you don't
know
moonshine is pretty much a homemade
alcohol that became popular due to
prohibition
the term moonshine comes from england
where it got its name because creating
moonshine was typically done at night
so people would not find out about it
now george's last words would take care
of our family
and this could also be a reason as to
why montrose killed yahima earlier in
the season
we learned from letty that d is getting
worse and worse which is when hippolyta
returns home
as we stated last week the showrunners
did clarify that h did not come back
after the events of episode 7
and this is why dee was on her own in
the last entry
it is good to see her back here and yeah
i'm quite surprised that it's taken her
this long to return
i cut across town to captain lancaster's
forces
and we learned that the coloration on
his body is because the character had
been kidnapping black people
and using them as sort of transplants
this magic is no longer working
and due to the amulet that ruby placed
in his office the captain's new bodies
are constantly being torn apart
this is because regeneration can cause
one to heal fully
or it can actually regenerate the wounds
that one has and thus its usage here has
become a curse
the police very much view black people
as disposable
people that they can just kidnap and
kill to further their agenda
it's quite a difficult scene to watch
due to the language used
we did discover that hiram epstein whom
lancaster had been friends with
experimented on black people and changed
their bodies in several ways
so it is possible that this knowledge is
what gave lancaster his ability to do
this
christina or rather william arrives and
removes the amulet and states that she
did this as revenge for william
as we know lancaster killed him and
christina has had to almost face his
death every time she transforms back
from him into herself
he watches lancaster die and it's a big
diversion from the book once more
as in that lancaster was a huge part of
the finale but it does look like they
are changing things up quite a bit for
next week
now christina could have saved lancaster
in order to save d
so her doing this does show that she is
indeed
operating with ulterior motives now i've
kind of done these bits out of order to
streamline the video a bit
but from here we jump back to d being
worked on by christina
h is now the closest blood relative and
thus they can restore her
we see that d is almost completely like
topsy and bopsy who last week we stated
were riffing on the pick in any
stereotype
the scene is very much an exorcism of
the curse i don't know if it's just me
but i got a lot of vibes of the opening
of constantine
though i'm sure that too is riffing on
real-world performances
of rituals like this now as christina
exits
ruby goes with her but letty tries to
talk her out of it
i think ruby very much represents
someone that is only really in it for
themselves
and they will look the other way out
what society does in order to have
safety and security it's at this point
that letty deduces christina will kill
tick
and ruby just doesn't really seem to
care at one point when she learns more
about dell
she also realizes that letty was right
but still doesn't do anything about it
instead she turns off dull's machine and
says she wants to be a redhead
enabling christina even more to carry
out her plan to kill tick
now what's weird about their
relationship is that ruby
really thinks she's getting equality
when becoming a white woman
and that all her problems will go away
however we know from christina that that
isn't the case
i find it really interesting that ruby
wants to become a white woman
more than anything whereas christina who
is a white woman
wants to become a white man even if she
does get her wish
ruby will still be subservient to
christina and it's very much this
illusion of power that christina is
giving her
when in reality she's still near the
bottom of the ladder
django and chain did a brilliant job of
bringing this to life
and it's very much a master and slave
setup but the slave here believes that
they are equal to the master
ruby holds a full deck of cards at one
point and this could symbolize that she
believes she holds
all the cards a saying that is often
used to state that someone has power
that simply isn't true though ruby is
pretty much at christina's beck and call
and will even lie to herself that she
has her best interests at heart
now it is difficult fully describing the
situation using understandable analogies
so apology for any offense caused with
the master and slave usage
as it's not intended but i do think
that's what the show is trying to
portray
now we learn more about dell and that
she del
into a coma after lettie hit her in the
head
this should be a massive red flag to
ruby but it's not
and she believes that christina isn't
using her
she might not be but i don't take it
that way probably because of the way i
have the book's story looming over my
head
so let me know what you think in the
comments section below
back with h tick letty and montrose we
learned that the time machine
is actually a multiverse machine and
that hippolyta was in earth 504 for 200
years
and this is imbued her with an almost
endless knowledge of the possibilities
that they could have
h is still obviously angry that they
lied about george but they pack up and
head out
now what's interesting is that they
arrive in kentucky at the observatory
but the one in episode 7 was set in
mayfield
maybe atticus actually traveled to
another dimension and that's what we've
been seeing since the end of episode
seven
as there are slight differences here and
i do think it goes beyond just a stupid
continuity error
i don't really know much about american
geography though or english for that
matter
so let me know if i brog as well which i
probably am
now they fixed the multiverse machine
and montrose and letty discuss
parenthood and what it means to protect
one's child both have done things they
shouldn't have in order to make sure
their kid is okay
and it's nice seeing the two understand
one another better in this moment
h uses her new abilities to set the
coordinates to tulsa 1921
and they travel back through an almost
bioshock infinite like tear
i don't know why they couldn't just have
avengers end game the book and got the
pages from another reality but but never
mind now montrose doesn't want to head
back
and we know that he still suffers from
ptsd over the day
even the smell of burning reminds him of
the massacre
however he returns and we see the full
depths of exactly what happened to him
the show does a fantastic job of
recreating the era
and hats off to hbo for making just such
a phenomenal season
i loved how letty couldn't find any
shoes in the past and so
she just wore her normal sneakers and
there are nice little easter eggs
started throughout the entry here and
there that really
you know give attention to detail we
also see a sign for buster keaton's the
ghost
and this is a 1921 silent film in which
a man is wrongly accused of a crime
and must go on the run from the police
this could be a comment on how the
massacres themselves started
and they began when 19 year old dick
roland was accused of assaulting a 17
year old white woman
this was revealed not to be the case but
prejudice at the time
led to him being jailed almost instantly
rumors spread that he was going to be
lynched
and 75 black men arrived at the jail
where he was held
in order to stop this from happening the
sheriff assured them that it wouldn't
and as they were leaving a group of
white men tried to disarm them
which led to shots being fired 12 people
were killed
and this angered the white people of the
city who then descended on the black
population mercilessly
montrose suffers from the memory over
this and take pretty much discerns him
completely
we see firsthand why the past of tulsa
is so harrowing
and learned that montrose's father beat
him publicly in the street
for wearing george's prom jacket and for
putting a flower in his hair
we have theorized that montrose's dad
beat him and avoided george most of the
time because he knew he was gay
and this is pretty much confirmed here
dora tick's mother came to his rescue
and it's likely that she married
montrose in order to save him from
persecution
letty and tick are so caught up in this
that they don't actually catch montrose
running off
which they assume is to warn george
about the future
they hot wire a car and leddy says that
they should name their son george
which as we know from tick's journey to
the future is what they call him
the sun sets on the town and as we know
from the series so far
sundown metaphorically means that black
people are in danger
we see this firsthand when lighty is
chased and shot at by some of the white
mob
she's protected by the invulnerability
spell put on her by christina
as well as tick's grandfather and dora's
dad as we know
these people are doomed to die and let
you wrestles with it throughout their
encounter after she speaks to dora's
sister
who's filled with the regret that she
will never get to make things right
across town we see montrose isn't
actually there to warn george
and he is in fact there to save the
first man he ever fell in love with
who we learn is called thomas on that
night montrose met him to
tell him that he couldn't be with him
and the elder version of the character
views this as a chance to save him
however tick won't let him
as it will change so much of the future
and thus he just has to stand there and
watch the event play out
the younger montrose calls in the f-word
denies himself
in order to fit in i actually recently
listened to the michael rosenborn
podcast inside of you with lance bass
and he discussed how when he was at
school he'd make gay jokes in order to
avoid persecution and it very much feels
that
that's the same sort of thing happening
here montrose thinks that as he's not
tick's father
this won't change anything but in the
end he's held back from doing what he
really wanted to
similar to his younger self it's such a
tough watch
and this show it deserves all the emmys
this year
now thomas is of course shot by the mob
and across town they assemble
outside the house and throw molotov
cocktails in to burn everything down as
we know from the stories we've heard of
tulsa
a man arrived to save the young kids
swinging a baseball bat like jackie
robinson
and tick takes up this mantle after
realizing that he was always the person
that did this
this story was so ingrained into his
head that he even dreamt about it in the
first episode
and it's amazing to see it happen first
hand here bringing everything full
circle
he utters the famous words i got you kid
and in the background
we hear sonia sanchez's poem catch the
fire
that he gains the pages and we very much
get the idea of generational sacrifice
with the family having to remain behind
in order to burn up in the property
so that the future doesn't change letty
leaving the house through the flames is
very similar to hannah escaping the
lodge
i love the repetition here as she walks
back to the future
the town descends into a war zone and we
remember
just how harrowing this event really was
it doesn't shy away from anything
naming names and the deaths that were
caused by it
and i'm glad that this moment in history
is finally getting the light it deserves
now every one of the trio makes it out
but h has difficulty holding the portal
open
eventually she powers through it though
much like how dora's mother did the fire
and we witness as her hair turns blue
making her completely become
orinthia blue it's a great little
conclusion and that ends the episode and
also seals atticus's fate
now as for next week spoilers ahead for
the trailer
but from the looks of it they are indeed
heading back to autumn
atticus gets baptized at one point
likely to protect himself from
christina's magic
but it doesn't seem like it's really
gonna help
she still seems to go ahead with her
plan and it seems like ruby
is gonna be the one who has to decide
who she wants to be with
she can either sacrifice christina or
her family
and i really think that she's the
character that's gonna have to make the
tough decision next week
there's also one last secret and though
i don't know what it is
i think there's no secret that i love
this episode
and i can't believe that the show
somehow gets better and better every
week
it's very bittersweet that our next
episode will be on the finale
but thanks for sticking with me through
all this so far now obviously i'd love
to hear your thoughts on the entry
so make sure you comment below and let
me know if you missed our breakdown of
last week then make sure you check it
out after this
and don't forget we're also giving away
three copies of the marvel phase one box
set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below the winner is
going to be chosen at random on the 30th
of october so make sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get the contents early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on a
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you been the best i've been
paul
i'll see you next time take care peace
[Music]
you